the united states postal service is now
thinking
about closing post offices around the
country
ahead of a presidential election in
which we are anticipating more people
than ever will vote by mail because of
this thing called
the global coronavirus pandemic which
has been
acutely mishandled by donald trump now
we're going to be talking today about a
lot of angles on vote by mail
including how to vote by mail but this
is
i think where it makes sense to start we
knew when it looked like vote by mail
was going to be a big deal this november
that the post office was going to be a
target and part of the reason why is
republicans love going after the post
office
even when there's not a pandemic and
when people are not particularly
planning to vote by mail trump
loves talking about how the post office
is inefficient
republicans love talking about
privatization ups fedex they're better
than the post office the post office is
kind of a perfect target for people like
donald trump and many republicans
because
you can talk about privatizing while
shrinking government
while attacking government inefficiency
and saying stuff like if the post office
can't even get it right
how could we possibly have the
government handle health care that's
often the way they like to talk about it
and then while we were already
suspicious about trump's plans for the
post office
trump goes and appoints a huge donor
from his campaign a donor to his
campaign rather louis de joy
as postmaster general who immediately
starts talking about
reevaluating the post office talking
about a fresh
look at the post office limiting
overtime hours for postal workers
and then we get a clearer picture of
what the plan is
we've now heard from democratic senator
joe manchin of west
virginia that he has been receiving
letters that there are plans
for closures of post offices in the
state
of west virginia which may just be the
very beginning of this strategy
when mansion sent a letter to trump's
new postmaster general to essentially
say
what on earth is going on here he got
some vague response
similar to what we we already talked
about you know we need to take a fresh
look at how the post office should be
run
now i actually found a document from the
congressional research service called
common questions about post office
closures
and it explains how and under what
circumstances post office
branches can be closed and when you look
at this document on page nine
it says what is that process and
uh the the federal law around
closing post offices includes that there
must be adequate notice
of the intention to close or consolidate
branches
at least 60 days prior to the proposed
date of the closure
and if a decision is made to close a
post office everybody served by that
post office must be notified
and the post office has to wait at least
60 more days before proceeding with the
closure
anybody who is served by a post office
that may be closing
has the right to appeal the closure
and there will be up to 120 days to
consider the appeal
so if you just look at the calendar it's
already too late to close post offices
before the election
by the normal process how can you get
around this
i'm guessing you you understand the way
this is going to go
emergencies there is something called an
emergency suspension process
but the situations where you can use
such a process to close a post office
branch
is very very limited these are limited
situations for example if the post
office is in a building
that you rent from you know a landlord a
private landlord
and the landlord closes the building as
an example
you would be able to close the post
office the post office would have no
choice in that case but to close
sooner than the normal timeline but
right now we certainly don't meet that
standard and
if kids are going back to school you
can't really argue that it's safe for
kids to be in school but post offices
have to close
so here's the plan that they're cooking
up cut over time
if carriers can't finish their daily
deliveries without taking overtime
they have to bring the undelivered mail
back to the post office the next day
they've got to take out the new mail
plus the leftover stuff from day one
can't finish it by 5 pm
bring it all back to the post office day
3 you now have to deliver that day's
mail
plus the leftovers from day one and the
leftovers from day two i think you
understand that's part of the plan
and meanwhile look at whether
they might be able to shut down some
branches as donald trump continues to
publicly assail
the ability of the post office to
deliver
absentee ballots now that's the plan it
doesn't match up with reality
and the postal service has actually uh
said not trump's postmaster but
others in the postal service have said
we have that we've got this we can
handle
the the ballots that's really not a big
deal for us donald trump however
is going to continue casting doubt about
that and that's what we're going to talk
about next
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much
i love my helix mattress well i was
really excited to hear that helix has
launched a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built it's
huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it
and the best part is everything comes
with a lifetime warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
20 off your entire order when you get
there
by going to all dot com slash pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video